who would win in a battle this giant
ancient enderman or this titan gas 10
giga zombies or this massive titan ender
dragon i'm gonna need you to pick a side
which one do you think will win 250
military soldiers or these 10 mutated
zombies i'm going with the army zombies
soldiers and now that the pig size start
the battle
oh my god oh my god they just smashed
them go zombies
25 soldiers are dead they're massacring
them we haven't even lost a zombie yet
yeah we got one oh wait what
what what just happened wait we can do
it there's only two left please
please oh there's only one what just
happened oh my god you got this it's 9v1
get long kill up
the military one which means chandler
and nolan each get one point and chris
has zero we're now at the second
battlegrounds there's 250 hope zombies
versus one titan mech and before you
guys pick i have 10 000 of my feastable
chocolate bars behind me and whoever
gets the most right in this video gets
them chocolate anyways pick a side all
right zombies i get meg i call the mech
server start
destroy him
all right the meg's taking some damage
i'm not gonna lie holy those rockets oh
i can't even see what's going on there's
so much destruction you guys are screwed
i'm gonna win this
oh what just happened oh we can win we
can win there's only 30 zombies we can
win we can win
you guys are losers if you win i'm gonna
be so pissed i can't hear you over the
two points that i have up next is one
titan mega boss tank versus 50 puny
tanks small tanks i'm gonna pick the big
tank i'm going with chris server start
the challenge
this time tank sucks
oh
he just shot a billion missiles all
right we got rid of three tanks so far
bro your titan's gonna ram hey this is
some big attacks right here this is a
big boy
oh no i just lost so many tanks
oh i lost yeah
big boy hey chris you finally got a
point i'm proud of you on the left is 50
crimson mex and on the right is chris's
mom i call chris's mom i'm against
chris's mom you know what i'm against my
mom too begin
oh
yeah
chris your mom is really strong we've
only lost one mech and look how fast my
mom's health is going
oh he jumped oh body slam
we just lost eight chris one more belly
flop oh here we go
oh they're why are they getting right
underneath it now
your mom's gonna win come on five left
belly flop
this guy's killing it back here this guy
knows the strat
no
no
oh he's missing
yes yes yes yes yes shoot him oh no get
up get up why are you going to him what
are you doing
yes
the mother of all mothers no one can
defeat chandler is now in first place
chris you're a monster why am i a
monster because monster legends is the
sponsor of this video you mean the hip
free to play game on ios and android
exactly and they've even given us a
third beast monster how many monsters
are there literally thousands in monster
legends you can collect and train with
other monsters battle other players or
try to conquer a venture map in dungeons
yeah but can you breed your monsters
there are thousands of monsters and you
can combine them to create new epic
monsters monster legends just launched
their fifth era which focuses on mother
nature and nature forces and monster
legends just launched a special in-game
event to promote their new era all you
have to do is participate in this event
and use special coins to clean up the
monster legends island and every time a
new milestone is reached all the players
will receive an in-game reward and if we
hit the final milestone monster legends
will donate ten thousand dollars to
beast's philanthropy wait how do i play
all you have to do is click the link in
the description and once you download it
you'll get 50 000 food 300 000 gold 10
gems and 10 mr beast monster cells just
for using my link act quick because
these rewards are only available until
march 17th click the link down below the
video right now and download monster
legends up next we have our giant
mutated cursed zombie with a mile long
sword versus ten max giant mutated
zombie with a mile long sword i'm gonna
choose the zombie from my nightmares i
don't know what to pick well it looks
like you're stuck with the other option
it's about time i let you guys get a win
so start the giant swinging zombie sword
guy
walking through his death
oh wait bro they're starting to do some
serious damage
oh this zombie is done for
he has another health bar
what the heck is this what are those
spikes he's turning the ground into lava
is there any way the mechs can win
holy crap i didn't know he was going to
transform into a freaking monster nolan
and chandler are tied for the lead chris
as usual isn't this is where things
officially get crazy that giant mutated
zombie with a mile long sword there's
now 10 of them going up against one
ancient enderman yeah i'm going with the
enderman i'm not gonna lie this thing is
crazy i'm gonna go with the enderman i
think i'm gonna go with sword bros
chandler you start the battle when
you're ready
i'm
ready oh he's got laser eyes
what
oh they're just taking damage the
zombies are getting hell out
oh he's melting you what is going on the
zombies are getting stuck behind the
spikes oh he's just corner camping them
he's getting sucked in he's like last
hope right here
bro they barely did any damage hey chris
if you didn't want to give everyone you
love thousands of chocolate bars you
could just said so maybe my family is on
a diet jimmy have you ever thought of
that what do you think this next battle
is a frog it's not a frog it's actually
ten titan tanks versus a giant mutant
weird looking gas yo look guys i'm gonna
go inside chandler's mom's mouth
gentlemen you know what to do i pick gas
i'm going with my mom all right i'll
choose the tanks i wish i could have
chandler's mom though i'm getting this
chocolate and you're not getting any of
it chris can i get a good old yeehaw to
kick it off yeehaw
whoa chandler's mom just got so angry
stop it
shoot chandler's bomb in the mouth
jailer's mom is shooting tons of balls
[Music]
he's attacking me we're on the same team
chandler
oh here comes the big tank damage
yo what what is this she summoned satan
oh my god
how am i supposed to compete with
chandler's mom
oh it's 1v1 all right come on gas let me
win they're making fun of me
yes chandler is currently in first place
screw you nolan i stood no chance we are
currently in the middle of nowhere
there's nothing here until now spawn him
in server
oh whoa it's taylor's mom again who do
you think will win chandler's mom or the
ancient endermen ancient enderman
ancient oh i guess i'm gonna go with
chandler's mom chris can you give us a
yeehaw to kick things off yey
it's beating your mom in the pie hole
they're just yelling at each other oh
it's it's kind of close
oh the demon rings are coming out
teleport you fat enderman go somewhere
oh
what is that oh look up bro what is that
up there
oh that's doing damage right there yo
nolan you're screwed
what the heck
bye-bye
how is that fair at all you should have
picked the enderman i told you on the
right side of the arena we have the
undefeated ancient endermen versus the
giant ender titan dragon now chris and
nolan both have five points chandler has
six gentlemen this is for all the
chocolate bars to be fair i'll give you
a chance and i'll go dragon i pick
enderman i'm gonna choose the
underdragon all right start it
oh no then we're losing i'm so stupid
oh
what
let's
picture frames what are these picture
frames
[Music]
he's shooting stuff through the pictures
oh they're multiplying
yo look at them just dodging they're not
doing that much damage
what are those orbs
they're spawning in the parallel
dimension let's see what happens to the
dragon
no wait what is that
yo what anime is this
oh the ender dragon just quick
chandler picked the ender dragon which
means he has the most points chandler
congratulations on winning ten thousand
chocolates
if you ate three chocolate bars a day it
would take you a decade to eat all 10
000 of these so i recommend you give
them away okay